welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Star Wars Episode two attack of
the clones aim to interweave mystery
romance and war and failing those
strategists and fanservice as a grade
schooler did I understand the motives of
Count Dooku nope but did I buy a Dooku
lightsaber yep
and before I begin quick thanks to
Marvel collect my tops for sponsoring
this breakdown stick around later for
some details on a chance to win some
very cool prizes as I've been rewatching
all the Star Wars films leading up to
the release of the rise of Skywalker
I've discovered that the prequels and it
seems all over the films actually are a
story about one man and one man only
sheev Palpatine aka Darth Sidious aka
the Emperor everything he loved and
didn't love about attack of the clones
was a result of all sheaves schemes
let's analyze this movie beat for beat
for the evidence and other interesting
details that you may have overlooked
okay the opening crawl unveils a title
attack of the clones or telling the
backstory into that in the original Star
Wars build years ago you served my
father in the Clone Wars
clones of this film are the clone
troopers of the army of the Republic
which would lead to the enemy Imperial
Stormtroopers during the Galactic Civil
War what is this title actually
referring to a more discrete clone
attack that we didn't realize I'll
explain how later the film opens with an
assassination attempt on now senator
Padme Amidala George Lucas based this
fictional political drama on real-world
history in the way this assassination
attempt lights the fuse that leads to
the rapid militarization and Palpatine's
dictatorship parallels the assassination
of Archduke Franz Ferdinand which
sparked World War one also the burning
of the German Reichstag in 1933 which
annulled Hitler used as the basis to
seize absolute control of Germany this
was carried out by assassins AM whistle
working for Jango Fett working for Count
Dooku working for Sidious I always ate
your assistants assistant assistant to
do your dirty work for you this
conspiracy is presented as a mystery
that unfolds throughout the film but
like any great episode of SVU the man
behind the curtain is revealed right
away
Master Yoda do you think it will really
come to war
under the guise of asking for counsel
Palpatine is testing Yoda here he's
sizing up the perception abilities of
the Jedi High Council we learned later
in this film that all the Jedi have
actually grown weaker in naive over the
years I think it is time we informed the
Senate that our ability to use the force
is diminished and here the Dark Lord of
the Sith is confirming the blindness of
his enemies Yoda was redesigned in the
attack of the clones as a CGI character
after complaints that his puppet form
and a Phantom Menace looked a bit off
George Lucas and designer Rob Coleman
used the original puppet form from the
Empire Strikes Back as a basis restoring
the characters old Miss and soreness and
frigidity and how the ears should jiggle
just a little bit when he moves his head
the Jedi's naivete is further underlined
in their defense of Dooku
I think the Count Dooku is behind it he
is a political idealist not a murderer
you know milady Count Dooku was once a
Jedi he couldn't assassinate anyone it's
not in his character Oh Sam Jackson if
only you could have the guard of your
other characters last time I trusted
someone I lost an eye Mace Windu's pride
over the incorruptible character of Jedi
foreshadows his blind spot to panic ins
upcoming turn Palpatine further sets
things in motion by recommending Padme
receive Jedi bodyguard on Kenobi whom he
knows is being accompanied by his
apprentice Anakin hoping to distract the
most vocal opponent to his army plan but
also distract the young Jedi that he
plans to corrupt do it for me milady
please the thought of losing you
is unbearable and I love that side i
Palpatine fixes on them as they move
forward
it'll be blinking in no time
before we continue thank you to marvel
collect my tops for sponsoring this
episode unlock a world where you can
collect and trade Marvel characters can
bring your collection life by earning
rewards for completing sets trade in
lower level or duplicate cards to
receive more special limited ones and
much more new collectibles are released
every day Marvel collect buy tops is
available in both the iTunes App Store
and Google Play Store worldwide and is
free to download and free to play
December is Fan Appreciation Month and
to celebrate an in-app tops digital is
giving away one very collectible every
day of the month for Marvel collects
users to collect and complete these sets
of 30 users can collect cards from days
in the month that have already passed
even if they didn't sign in that day
check out my progress I have two of the
five so far Black Widow and Captain
America can't wait to get the rest of
the five though so I'll be checking in
throughout December to share my progress
by completing these steps you can enter
for a chance to win $1,000 worth of
Disney comic gift cards $250 Midtown
comics digital gift card or $100 worth
of in-app currency click the link in the
description to download marvel collect
app register username and then collect
b5 that fan appreciation character cards
located in the free section of the pack
store once all five are collected you
will be eligible to win the giveaway be
sure to follow at tops marvel on twitter
and at tops digital on instagram just
download marvel click buy tops digital
trading card app to start collecting and
trading your favorite characters with
fans around the world the app is free to
play and new cards are released every
day download now from the link below and
all right away anakin skywalker now
played by aiden christensen does not
make a good first impression we will not
go through this exercise again Anakin
and you will pay attention to my lead
why what seconds before this obi-wan and
Anakin we're laughing it up about
falling into nests of gundarks
in the moment and against these Padme
he's all football food hoes before Bros
all of these earlier scenes cast a very
toxic shadow over Anakin and Edna's
remains she
the cameras I don't think she liked me
watching her please don't look at me
like that it makes me feel uncomfortable
you're exactly the way I remember you in
my dreams
Li's that keeper George Lucas tried to
model Anakin and Padme Zwarte I'm
romance on the film Doctor Zhivago even
had attack of the clones poster modeled
on a Chicago poster both couples are
forbidden loves between figures who pose
as refugees and run away to country
retreats but Wow the great romance of
dr. Zhivago is rooted in the difficult
moral decisions of the characters the
love between Anakin and Padme really
just happens because the script says so
there is no reason an intelligent driven
senator like Padme
should fall for a what is he a bratty
monk trainee who insults belittles and
creeps her out repeatedly some have even
theorized that the fainted quality of
their romance was actually part of
Palpatine's orchestration some kind of
SIF brainwashing to trap Padme in the
sunken place and that's one way to
describe that dialogue but I do believe
Palpatine intentionally paired Anakin
with the female that he first imprinted
on after leaving his mother [ __ ] she
schemes later they save Padme from the
Koons to chase down zanthor course on
first mention that we've ever gotten of
Yoda's lightsaber skills foreshadowing
the big reveal in the final act and as
they died in a bottom left corner of the
screen notice the animators snuck in
three type fighters pursuing an x-wing a
nod to luke's trench run in a new hope a
dogfight that Anakin's a spy lighting
skills here are foreshadowing
even if these ships don't yet exist in
the Star Wars history and they chase
damn into a club why do I get the
feeling you're going to the dance with
me this place is filled with cameos
including repo actor Anthony Daniels Jar
Jar actor I'm at best George Lucas's
daughter Katie Matt doranikov a mouse
from the matrix and the character Mouse
designed the woman in the red dress
actress Fiona Johnson distracting Anakin
this simulation in Palpatine's office
are these statutes these are the four
stages of dwarf philosophers and law
givers from the early days of the
Republic and other stories Palpatine
takes particular interest in the hooded
figure Syst roasts in which he later
hides a SIF lightsaber and cool
attention to detail here when Padme
packs up you can see repair droids
replacing the broken window from the
assassination attempt earlier Obi Wan's
investigation plays out similarly to
films like Blade Runner obi-wan like
Harrison Ford's Deckard unravels
conspiracy about synthetic beans at
almost cost him his life and leaves them
questions about the ethics of playing
God the Jedi Archives was modeled on the
long room in the Trinity College Library
in Dublin now the busts are those of
members of the starwars staff including
George Lucas one of them also is the
face of Dooku which we see in a deleted
scene between obi-wan in the library in
Jocasta new and the young Jedi who
approaches her at the end of the scene
is George Lucas's son
he later cameos in Revenge of the Sith
the young Jedi defending Bail Organa
know where they go to Naboo you can see
what looks like the Millennium Falcon
but really these are just generic white
sea thirteen hundred freighters
however the Falcon does make a cameo in
episode three we'll get to that in the
next breakdown or two trails behind them
showing that he can in fact go upstairs
he cannot however go downstairs and his
ability to descend the steps in Javas
palace and return to Jedi was later
justified and headcanon to many of us by
r2 using his boosters revealed later in
this film
so obi-wan learns that the Kamino ins
had been building a clone army at the
orders of Jedi Master sifo-dyas
originally sifo-dyas was written to be a
simple alias as sido Diaz for Darth
Sidious but after a typo in George
Lucas's script made it appear as Scifo
Lucas developed a backstory for this new
Jedi character that would later be
filled in by an episode of the Clone
Wars
alive you are help me please
you're dumb
I have been imprisoned on Jeopardy s was
shot down by the Pyke's who were hired
by Taranis / Dooku who then took over
funding for the Clone Army with his
family's immense wealth it was actually
cyclo Diaz who instructed the cloners to
add order 66 to the clones control chips
as a safeguard against treacherous
orders given to the clones unfortunately
it would be used in a very dark ironic
way so these clones were cloned from the
Bounty Hunter Jango Fett whom obi-wan
meets along with the constant stinkface
clone he's raising personally as his son
boba fett jango and later Boba's armor
is Mandalorian Jango was a foundling
brought in by the people of Mandalore in
the Clone Trooper Armour is derived from
the Mandalorian design obi-wan and Janko
fights and as Jango escapes in a ship
slave one later Boba Fett's ship he
bumps his head on the door it's a
callback to the stormtrooper famously
bumping his head on the Death Star in a
new hope meanwhile on Naboo this happens
I don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere
[Music]
also this people don't always agree well
then they should be made to sounds an
awful lot like a dictatorship to me well
if it works also this how was that last
one the weirdest during all this
Anakin's suffering nightmares about his
mother Shmi so they were turned to
Tatooine they find Watteau in the large
family including younger versions of
Owen and Beru Anakin's dramatic reunion
with his mother was actually part of
Palpatine's manipulations see the Tusken
Raiders were actually paid to kidnaps me
by Dooku at the orders of Sidious
something that was meant to be revealed
in Revenge of the Sith before was rude
so all according to Palpatine's plan
anakin goes apeshit on the Tusken
Raiders actually the Star Wars legends
novel Tatooine ghosts suggest that
Anakin slaughter is pasta into Tuscan
folklore is a kind of ghost story and
Yoda senses this violence hearing the
voice of high ganj in there the Clone
Wars animated series explains that
qui-gon is one of the first Jedi to
access the spiritual realm of the force
and it's believed that he was present
during Anakin slaughter of the Tusken
Raiders as a force ghost trying to talk
him down from his rage then back in the
farms garage in the background of Luke's
land speeder from a new hope in an early
version of the t16 skyhopper that Luke
flies and and it can read just about how
he killed all of the Tusken Raiders and
not just the men but the women and the
children too
they're like animals and I slaughtered
them like animals I hate them composer
John Williams underscores this dark turn
by first including the Emperor's theme
to reflect Palpatine's corruption of
Anakin's soul and then this gives way to
the Imperial March
[Music]
who's single Anakin's coming
transformation into Bator as a result of
this anger obi-wan pursues slave 1 to
Geonosis one of the orbiting asteroids
is actually designed in the shape of one
of those dumb cow like shocks of Naboo
and obi-wan hides by parking this ship
on the backside of an asteroid which is
exactly how a young Boba Fett's learned
this trick when he will later pursue Han
through the asteroid field in the Empire
Strikes Back obi-wan spies on Count
Dooku who despite being mentioned in the
opening crawl and several times since
only now appears one hour in sixty
minutes into the film he's played by
veteran of stage and screen and
Christopher Lee so minute back story on
Dooku he was once a Jedi Master who had
quite gone gen as his apprentice and
Yoda as his master but he became
disillusioned with the Jedi Order and
left it to reclaim his birthright as
Count of Serenno during this time of
exile he was approached by Sidious who
offered to help him attain more power in
rid corruption from the Republic but
like all the apprentices insidious
approach over the years he's really just
a tool for him so after a failed rescue
attempt of obi-wan in the battle droid
factory Anakin and Padme end up beside
him in the execution arena facing an AK
lay a week in annex 2 but they're saved
with the arrival of the rest of the Jedi
led by mace Windu and his purple
lightsaber this party's over Samuel
Jackson actually had the words bad
mother engraved on the hilt as a
reference to his wallet and Pulp Fiction
now Windu ends up killing Jango Fett's
which has a few really interesting
details leading up to it Windu
foreshadows is beheading of Jango by
first igniting this blade right at
Django's neck this happens it's Jango is
holding his Mandalorian helmet his hands
boba will later do when he warns him
notice that the framing also points that
blade at Baba's neck to applying that
both Django's and vobis deaths will be
linked and indeed as we saw with Boba
Fett returned the Jedi Jango also dies
because his jetpack malfunctions
notice how he tries to take off but he
can't he's left standing there a dead
man the reek trampled him moments before
and Lucas actually added a couple sparks
to signal the jetpacks brokenness and
after Windu behead Zim
notice that there are two shadows as a
Mandalorian helmet flies off the second
shadow for Django's severed head the
surviving Jedi are saved by the clone
troopers thanks to senator Binks making
the move to grant Chancellor Palpatine
emergency War Powers so laugh it up
fuzzball Jar Jar was the key to all this
as Dooku flees he reveals preliminary
blueprints for the Death Star actually
because the Death Star's early
construction on Geonosis
the gene oceans were exterminated via
sterilization ordered by the Emperor
killing all of them off except one named
Click Clack kinda sucks to be the sole
survivor of your species and be named
click-clack
obi-wan and Anakin and catch up to Dooku
and they approach very patiently well
I'm taking now no I could no no blue and
red light flashes across Anakin's face
signaling the moral tug-of-war between
good and evil currently inside him
Anakin gets his arm severed the first of
many body parts that will be replaced by
machine as he loses his humanity but the
big showdown arrives with Yoda Dooku was
an apprentice of Yoda himself and their
duel goes through three phases first by
using the force to launch and deflect
projectiles second with SIF lightning
and third only when they're forced
knowledge hits an evenly matched
standstill with a lightsaber duel with
Yoda for the first time ever revealing
that little green blade mmm Yoda only
losses by having empathy he saves the
others and John Williams works ending
Yoda theme music from Empire Strikes
Back in the moment Yoda lifted Luke's
x-wing from out of the swamp
[Music]
Dooku rejoined Sidious encore signs
everything is going as planned right
after this we see Sidious this alter ego
Palpatine
gazing upon this army like a fascist
autocrat set all to the Imperial March
[Music]
like in the Phantom Menace attack of the
clones ended in apparent victory for the
good guys but it's really a victory for
evil old conflict between the Republic
and the separatists is false
manufactured and played on both sides by
one man posing as - and while they're
not genetic clones Palpatine and Sidious
are metaphorical clones doppelgangers
who are really behind the attack of this
film's title also like this film's
predecessor some secrets are hidden in
the final scene Anakin and Padme secret
wedding is a visual homage to the final
shot of the other middle installment
Empire Strikes Back with Anakin and
Padme framed alongside r2 in Threepio
the same way Luke and Leia were but John
Williams music sneaks and yet another
detail if you're listening closely and
against cybernetic hand holds Padme sand
and open those ears as a frame rises
over her midsection
Williams included the softest bass
percussion here giving off the sound of
a heartbeat
now of course Padme couldn't yet be
pregnant there are three years between
this film and Revenge of the Sith and
only then does she discover her
pregnancy but this heartbeat hints at
the promise of what is to come
the real reason these two completely
mismatched lovers were brought together
look folks attack of the clones in my
book is the weakest of the Star Wars
films it's really just because the
romance between Anakin Padme
it's unwatchable it's terrible but this
subtle instrumental choice by Williams
reminds us that this is all surveying
the true beating hearts that made us
fall in love with the Star Wars series
this siblings that the framing of this
final shot is deliberately invoking Luke
Skywalker in its twin sister Leia and
for that we are left at the very least
with hope how does Attack of the Clones
rank among the Star Wars films in your
opinion my opinion it's dead last but
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram on twitter at a
loss and subscribe to our podcast feed
wikileaks / early access to all of our
Star Wars content thanks for joining me
see you next week bye
[Music]